at dick Darius and xerxes they are
actually common names in among Iranians
but so I wanted it to have that sort of
level of reality but they were both very
interesting Kings in Persian history and
I looked at a lot of Herodotus as
writings on the two and they were men
who were constantly wrapped up in
comedies of errors at both very great
kings but they seem like great muses for
my actual characters in examining the
sort of abstract accounts of their
histories they kind of became the ideal
and uses for them because Dirk sees
particularly was a sort of corrupt and
controversial king who was always
tripping over his own foot and so I like
I like the idea of toying with ancient
history a little bit playfully and
there's a sense in the novel that from
the minute they were given their names
and Darius particularly naming his son
Xerxes that they were cursed and I'd
like to toy with the with curses and
those sort of superstitions in the novel
a bit too well to what degree you know
is it sort of voodoo in hocus pocus to
say a particularly turbulent time and
history is causing a lot of the
psychological warfare between two men
that in itself seems like magical
thinking to me but it's thinking that
I've always been very immersed in and
interested in and looking at these you
know his these accounts in ancient texts
it's full of absurdities and psychology
is absent from it and that became quite
interesting a lot of Persian proverbs a
lot of the Persian mindset is informed
by superstitions and historical
superstitions and magical thinking I
wanted to give another option of how
Iran ians have approached assimilation
and there's definitely a lot of Iranians
who in the years after they came to the
States or Europe changed their names and
then I always find them comical you know
the Americanized versions of your on Ian
names you know you know my mother often
you know when she goes to pick up the
food delivery becomes Mary not managed
to you know our Mona you know some of
it's often been by accident you know the
the misspellings of one's name the
mother in my novels name was Lola a very
beautiful Persian name but she was often
getting mail where I would become Layla
Lily llena la la and eventually she
settles on la la she likes the way it
sounds that's all there is to it and she
she takes it up as a way to just make it
a little easier on herself and it
becomes one way to cope and she sort of
in a completely different sphere in the
novel from from the men she's all about
embracing America she's all about
fitting in she doesn't she in fact
doesn't understand the drama and she's
she's a very matter-of-fact character
interestingly she was the most
fabricated character I don't know anyone
like her she was wholly imagined and
she's nothing like my own mother for
instance
but uh but I i was very interested in
creating a strong character whose first
decisive move in the US was what some of
us would look at as not a strong move
and I think it ends up being surprising
her progress in the US